[Music]
earlier today Kate and William gave the
public a first quick glimpse of their
new child I don't know who saw this on
television it was all over the place a
couple hours ago
but you were all clearly in line for TV
show but I watched this you know I was
like oh here we go we're gonna see the
Royal baby they come out they stand
there for I don't know a minute or two
you could barely see you barely see it I
was like that's crazy a quick glimpse
it's been a nine-month build-up all they
do is walk out babies covered up almost
completely in a blanket and then they go
back behind these doors and the doors
shut that is no way to debut this baby
don't these people understand show
business come on
that's why at great personal expense
I've had the Royal child flown across
the pond right here to our studio for a
proper introduction American style
[Applause]
baby
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now there gonna be some guys on the
internet they're like skeptic skeptics
Andy yeah well I'm gonna prove that that
was the real baby let's show that for
did you get in slow motion you can tell
you just can't fake this kind of thing
yeah very exciting anyway I think the
baby's coming back
[Applause]
enjoy rises on atetv
okay baby there he goes
he's new he's a couple of hours old
you're all like oh he can't drive he's
driving on the wrong side of the studio
it's different over there in any way can
report that's the way you would debut a
royal but oh look he's he's surfing over
the audience
[Music]
kyouko thank you
this guy's like come back I know we
shouldn't spy clear oil baby well we
sent him down right among the baby
haters yeah they were clear as I can
please get off me
and then finally
anyway you're taking good care of them
man yeah
make sure he's well taken care of